[Music]
I'm at the kooky One World Taekwondo
headquarters here in Seoul today I'm
going to learn the great art of
self-defense and I think given the hour
that I have I should rise very high
maybe to the highest level they just
told me that they want to give a live
demonstration in my honor that they've
prepared this is the plastic chair of
Honor I've been given we are ten minutes
into the production and nothing has
happened I guess this is demonstrating
that the best defense is to not fight at
all
[Music]
I think this is the Korean Westside
story
okay this guy is beating me I'm with
maneuver to that gentleman right there
let's see what's happening whoa whoa if
you're attacked by two men making love
you just
[Music]
[Applause]
that's me in one hour I would like to
learn Taekwondo and I'd like to show you
my uniform how often have you been
attacked with plywood
[Applause]
broken back broken through boards to
boards to what five we've got one five
oh there's making me jump up from one to
five okay I'm gonna do it
[Music]
ah master song there is a person I work
with who irritates me this has a TDs
let's say for even this has a TDS
probably reverse that's why we know why
perfect I find Utes I would like you and
your students I don't know what how do
you say kick the to attack how
about I pretend to attack you with this
and you defend I do not make it work I
wait your time
[Music]
[Applause]
you